>> MASSACHUSETTS CALLING IN THE
NATIONAL GUARD TO DEAL WITH A
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS AFTER 50
MIGRANTS ARRIVED IN MARTHA'S
VINEYARD.
WHEN YOU GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM,
GOVERNOR DESANTIS FLORIDA AND
TEXAS GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT TO
BE CHARGED WITH KIDNAPPING FOR
RELOCATING MIGRANTS TO LIBERAL
CITIES WHAT CHARGES SHOULD THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FACE FOR
SECRETLY TRANSPORTING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY?
THAT HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR THE
PAST YEAR.
OUR NEXT GUEST EXPOSED THE
SECRET MIGRANT FLIGHTS TO HIS
STATE.
WESTCHESTER COUNTY NEW YORK
EXECUTIVE ROB ASTORINOH JOINS
US NOW.
THE WORD THAT IS BEING THROWN
AROUND, GOVERNOR NEWSOM ISSUED
IT, KIDNAPPING.
ARE THOSE TO BE APPLIED
UNIVERSALLY?
>> FEDERAL KIDNAPPING CHARGES,
DEFINITELY HUMAN TRAFFICKING BY
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, WE GO
ON AND ON AND ON, WE WOULD
PROBABLY RUN OUT OF CRIMES TO
CHARGE THEM WITH BUT I WANT TO
GO BACK TO WHAT YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT BEFORE, THIS IS
PRESENTISM BY THE PROGRESSIVES
BECAUSE A YEAR AGO WHEN I WAS
TALKING ABOUT THIS SHOWED THE
VIDEO WHAT WAS HAPPENING THEY
WERE DEAD SILENCE, THEY DID WAS
CALL ME A RACIST AND HATER AND
ALL THIS OTHER NONSENSE AND IT
WAS HAPPENING RIGHT INTO OUR
OWN NEIGHBORHOOD IN WESTCHESTER
COUNTY AND WENT TO STEWART
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT WHICH IS
NEW YORK STATE CONTROLLED PORT
AUTHORITY SO GOVERNOR HOCHUL
WAS IN ON IT.
MIGRANTS COMING INTO OUR
SCHOOLS, THEY ARE GETTING INTO
HOUSING, ALL THESE BENEFITS
THEY HAVE BEEN GETTING FOR A
YEAR SO NOW THAT THEY GO TO
MARTHA'S VINEYARD, AND GREAT
JOB, GOVERNOR DESANTIS, THE
PROGRESSIVES CAN'T TAKE IT SO
THEY ARE GOING BALLISTIC WHICH
PROVES 2 THINGS, ONE, THEY
ADMIT THERE'S A PROBLEM AND 2
THEY ARE INADEQUATE, THEY ARE
ENOUGH TO HANDLE THIS PROBLEM.
PETE: EXPLAIN THE DIFFERENCE IN
REACTION FROM A YEAR AGO TO
TODAY, IS INSTANTLY THAT NOW
THE OTHER POLITICAL PARTIES
DOING IT?
>> NO QUESTION.
I HAD A PRESS CONFERENCE
AUGUST 13, 2021, I HAD VIDEO,
AT NIGHTTIME IS FLIGHTS COMING
IN BUT IN BROAD DAYLIGHT, WE
FOLLOWED THE BUSES, WHERE THEY
WERE BEING TRANSPORTED ALL OVER
THE PLACE, GETTING INTO CARS,
THE BUSES WOULD STOP AT THRUWAY
REST STOP AND ALL THESE WAITING
CARS FOR THEM TO GET INTO AND
OFF THEY WOULD GO AND WE GOT NO
ANSWERS WHATSOEVER AND WHEN I
SAID THIS AND DEMAND ANSWERS I
WAS CALL THE HATER, A RACIST,
ALL THE TYPICAL RACIST STUFF
THEY SAID.
BUT I PURSUED, I WROTE A LETTER
TO PRESIDENT BIDEN FEBRUARY 1ST
OF THIS YEAR, STILL NOTHING, NO
ANSWERS WHATSOEVER.
I ASKED THE GOVERNOR OF NEW
YORK TO TRIGGER A LAW, THE
ABILITY TO DEMAND THAT ANY
PERSON HERE ILLEGALLY, ANY
FOREIGN NATIONAL THAT COMES IN
HERE MUST REGISTER WITH THE
STATE AS AN ALIEN AND NEW YORK
LAW, MUST REGISTER WITH NEW
YORK STATE WITHIN ONE DAY, THAT
WOULD STOP IT IN NEW YORK BUT
SHE'S NOT DOING IT BECAUSE NEW
YORK IS A SANCTUARY STATE AND
CITY AND THE SAME WITH MAYOR
ADAMS IN NEW YORK CITY.
THEY'VE BEEN COMING IN THROUGH
CATHOLIC CHARITIES AND OTHER
NONGOVERNMENT ORGANIZATIONS FOR
THE LAST YEAR AND NOT APPEAR
BUT NOW THEY HAVE TO DEAL WITH
WHAT EVERYONE ELSE ON THE
SOUTHERN BORDER HAS TO DEAL
WITH AND IT IS A MASSIVE BURDEN
WE ARE NOT PREPARED TO DO NOR
SHOULD WE.
RACHEL: LESS THAN 30 SECONDS,
HOW DOES IT PLAY POLITICALLY?
ON THE LEFT THEY SAY THIS HAS
BACKFIRED ON RUN DESANTIS, THEY
SEE A VICTORY IN THIS OR AT
LEAST PRETEND TO SEE A VICTORY
IN THIS FIGHT.
>> NOT AT ALL, YOU HAVE NORMAL
PEOPLE OF ALL POLITICAL STRIPES
SAYING WHAT IS GOING ON HERE?
I CAN TELL YOU IN MY KIDS HIGH
SCHOOL IN THEIR CLASSROOMS
THEY'VE GOT 5 OR SO EACH, 20
NEW KIDS IN THE CLASSROOM THE
DON'T SPEAKING.
GETTING SERVICES, PARENT OF ALL
STRIPES ARE SAYING ENOUGH IS
ENOU